à Tel Aviv il s'est entretenu avec
Benyamin netaniaahou pour exhorter
Israël à épargner les civils
palestiniens et a cessé de prendre des
mesures qui sappent la capacité des
Palestiniens à se gouverner eux-mêmes
Anthony blinan qui rencontre aujourd'hui
le président palestinien Mahmoud
[Musique]
Abbas merci an sévine de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu Paris membre du
groupe les républiqu he et
vice-président du parti on va évidemment
longuement revenir sur ce remanimement
et cette nomination hier de Gabriel
hatal est-ce que c'est le bon choix je
trouve que c'est un choix audacieux euh
et c'est vrai que le principal point
fort de Gabriel Attal c'est d'être issu
de la gauche mais d'avoir compris que la
France était à droite et donc c'est un
ministre très politique qui est très
lucide et pragmatique et donc j'espère
qu'il ne sera pas le simple
collaborateur du chef de l'État mais
qu'il saura comment dire ne pas se
soumettre en fait aux hésitations et en
même temps d'Emmanuel Macron et qu'il
ait une véritable colonne vertébrale une
feuille de politique claire et qu'il
rompe avec l'échec du macronisme et
qu'il a que la fin du en même temps
c'est un premier ministre de droite pour
vous qui a été nommé hier non pas du
tout comme je vous le disais il vient de
la gauche en revanche mais est-ce qu'il
fait une politique de droite bien
compris au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale il est vrai qu'il a pris des
décisions qui étaient très marquantes et
qui étaient plutôt favorable en tout cas
l'électorat de droite mais maintenant
nous on va juger sur les actes parce que
le vrai sujet c'est de savoir si la
France va mieux qu'il y a 6 ans
aujourd'hui notre France est fracturée
elle est minée par l'inflation elle est
miné par une crise du pouvoir d'achat il
faut rappeler qu'aujourd'hui 44 % des
Français se privent de chauffage alors
qu'on est dans un froid polaire on a un
tiers des Français qui aujourd'hui le 10
de chaque mois malheureusement donc que
moins de 100 € sur leur compte bancaire
une France également minée par une crise
financière avec une dette de 3000
milliards d'euros un matraquage fiscal
la France est championne d'Europe en
matière de de de de pression fiscale et
sociale et puis enfin une crise du
régalien une crise du régalien avec un
état qui est incapable de faire
respecter son autorité sur le territoire
national et on l'a vu qui n'arrive pas à
lutter contre l'immigration irrégulière
qui est un fiasco de ce point de vue-là
et donc vous exp il a dit hier la
sécurité ob prioritaire et la maîtrise
de l'immigration vous avez approuvé C
ces déclarations bien évidemment bien
évidemment mais encore une fois il est
important maintenant qu'on passe des
mots aux actes il ne faut pas que la
communication se substitue à l'action et
c'est là-dessus qu'on va l'attendre moi
je ne veux pas lui faire de procès
d'intention ce que je constate c'est que
il a compris une chose en dehors du fait
que la France était à droite il a
compris également que la politique c'est
l'art de l'exécution et qu'on l'a vu
quand il a été au ministère de
l'Éducation nationale une fois que il
prenait un sujet sur lequel il y avait
des discussions interminables sur
l'uniforme par exemple et bien il a
tranché il a dit on va expérimenter et
puis si ça marche et bien on pourra
éventuellement généraliser et donc il
faudrait que sur tous les sujets qui
sont des sujets de priorité pour les
Français notamment sur le pouvoir
d'achat qu'il prennent des vraies
décisions et qu'elles soi suivie des
faits parce que malheureusement ce qui
caractérisit Emmanuel Macron jusqu'à
maintenant c'est de beaucoup parler mais
malheureusement on n' pas vu les
résultats est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
aura des marges de manœuvre pour le
faire alors qu'il a redit hier il doit
tout au président de la République c'est
tout le sujet c'est tout le sujet c'est
pour ça que encore une fois je le redis
j'espère qu'il ne sera pas un simple
collaborateur et qu'au contraire il
s'affirmera véritablement comme un
Premier ministre qui prend des décisions
et qui ne se laisse pas dicter sa
feuille de route par l'Élysée ce sera
tout l'enjeu pour lui on espère qu'il a
réussira à s'affranchir justement du
fait qu'il doit tout qu'il estit la la
simple créature d'Emmanuel Macron
Gabriel Attal qui s'attelle à formmer
son nouveau gouvernement est-ce que vous
redoutez des débauches ch chez les
républicains écoutez les républicains
nous sommes nous dans une opposition
constructive intelligente nous avons
montrer que la droite parlementaire
était une une force politique qui qui
qui est fondamentale en fait dans la
dans la construction en fait des des des
des projets on l'a vu sur l'immigration
c'est la droite qui a réussi avec Bruno
rotaillo Eric cotti Olivier merlex à
fertiliser ce texte et donc nous
resterons évidemment une opposition
responsable et le plus intelligent
possible c'est-à-dire que si on se
soumet à Emmanuel Macron ça veut dire
que demain nos électeurs n'auront le
choix contre Renaissance ou les deux
pôles de radicalité moi je ne me résous
pas à l'idée que la droite républicaine
disparaisse du paysage politique c'est
pour ça que nous restons une opposition
utile au pays est-ce que l'opposition
utile ça veut dire discuter dès
maintenant avec Gabriel hatal sur
certains textes sur certaines réformes
pour les construire avec lui bien
écoutez vous savez jusqu'à maintenant on
nous a toujours dit Emmanuel Macron tend
la main à la droite et qu'on lui aurait
qu'on aurait fermé la porte non il se
trouve que vous savez en Allemagne quand
ils font en fait des des des
partenariats ils se mettent autour de la
table et il discuteent sur le fond des
projets nous on nous dit venez et on
verra ensuite quels seront les projets
ça n'est pas possible nous avons des
convictions vous savez la droite c'est
les républicains c'est un parti en fait
qui a une tradition nationale sociale
entrepreneuriale qui a donné cinq
présidents la France incarné par des
personnalités comme le général de Gaulle
Jacques Chirac Nicolas Sarkozi et donc
nous ne pouvons pas disparaître comme ça
nous avons un patrimoine idéologique qui
est là nous avons des convictions nous
restons fidèles à nos convictions et
donc nous continuons de penser
qu'aujourd'hui la droite est une
opposition utile et que elle fera tout
pour continuer de redresser la France
est-ce que vous attendez de gabrielal
qui s'exprime rapidement devant le
Parlement et qu'il se soumettent à un
vote bien écoutez c'est la tradition
c'est la tradition c'est c'est c'est la
tradition mais c'est n'est pas une le
vote pas
forcément prédcesseurs nont pas fait
est-ce que pour vous il doit se
soumettre à un vote ou pas écoutez
pourquoi pas il peut tout à fait il peut
tout à fait présenter d'abord son son
son discours de politique générale parce
que encore une fois je le redis il
arrive dans des circonstances où la
France va très très mal je je je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure il y a beaucoup de de
sujets sur le régalien sur la crise
financière sur l'inflation sur le
pouvoir d'achat on a vu que c'était une
des préoccupations majeures des Français
il faut aujourd'hui qu'il prennent des
décisions et d'ailleurs il l'a dit sur
le travail il faut que le travail soit
beaucoup plus rémunérateur aujourd'hui
que assistana il faut que le salaire net
puisse se rapprocher du salaire brut
parce qu'aujourd'hui une fois qu'on
touche un salaire entre les impôts les
cotisation et les charges il ne reste
plus rien et c'est ça en fait qui
dégoûte un peu les Français c'est de se
dire que la cistana paye plus que le
travail voilà et justement dans son
discours hier de lors de sa passation de
pouvoir il s'est adressé à à cette
classe moyenne à ces Français qui doute
mais qui espère c'est ce qu'il a dit
hier dans le Pas de Calais il a aussi
parlé à ces Français qui travaillent qui
se lèvent tôt le matin c'est le bon
message qu'il a envoyé dans dans les
premières heures écoutez là où encore
une fois il est assez lucide c'est qu'il
sait parler au français il a bien
compris que les Français attendent du
bon sens de la clarté de l'autorité et
puis qu'il répondent enfin à leur
préoccupation parce qu'encore une fois
jusqu'à maintenant on a le sentiment que
beaucoup de choses sont dites mais
qu'elles ne sont pas suivies des faits
et que il serait temps enfin de passer à
l'acte on le disait c'est vraine vous
êtes memre de la commion de l'éducation
ici au Sénat gabrielal qui a donc quitté
hier le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale moins de 6 mois après sa
nomination quitter peut-être
temporairement on verra ça dans les
prochaines heures un ministère dans
lequel il avait voulu imprimer sa marque
alors qu'elle est son bilan onue Steve
Jourdan notre journaliste
[Musique]
parlementaire bonjour St bonjour bonjour
madame la Sénat et bonne année et bonne
année à vous également on peut le dire
enc on peut jusqu'à fin janvier Gabriel
Atal a donc passé on disait un peu moins
de 6 mois à la tête du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale quel bilan jeune
jeune bilan jeune par l'âge puisqu'il
était déjà le plus jeune ministre à être
nommé Rud Grenel et puis jeune aussi par
la durée durée très courte de son
passage au ministère six petits mois et
puis s'en va et encore si on compte ça
c'est si on compte les vacances d'été si
on exclut les vacances d'été on dépasse
à peine le trimestre dès le départ il
fixe le cap et affiche une touche plus
conservatrice plus à droite que celle de
son prédécesseur
écoutez-le en ces temps troublés et
après ce que le pays a traversé au début
du mois de juillet il faut en revenir à
des choses simple le respect du
professeur et de son autorité la
maîtrise des savoirs fondamentaux le
respect de la laïcité alors que nous
sommes tous et tu l'as dit encore si
douloureusement meurtris par
l'assassinat de Samuel pati et quel
dossier ail fait avancer il a surtout
ouvert des chantiers Ori le plus
important peut-être le grand plan lancé
début décembre pour relever le niveau de
l'école mesure phare de ce plan la
création de groupe de niveau au collège
pour les maths et le français Gabriel
Atal a aussi annoncé la relance du
redoublement de classe enterré sous
François Hollande autre mesure forte
l'interdiction de laabaya à l'école on
en a beaucoup parlé il existait jusque-l
un flou juridique sur le port de ce
vêtement Gabriel viriier les choses
juste avant la rentrée de septembre via
une note de service adressée au chefs
d'établissement et puis parmi les sujets
autour desquels il a beaucoup
communiquer il a aussi celui du
harcèlement à l'école un mot d'ordre ne
rien laisser passer
écoutez chaque drame est un drame de
trop qui nous rappelle que nous ne
sommes toujours pas à la hauteur ce ne
sont pas des personnes évidemment que je
veux mettre en cause c'est la réponse de
l'institution éducation nationale face à
l'urgence du harcèlement scolaire qu'il
nous faut continuer à profondément
changer pour lutter contre le
harcèlement Gabriel Atal a annoncé
l'expérimentation de cours d'empathie en
maternelle et en primaire le dispositif
sera étendu à toutes les écoles à partir
de septembre autre expérimentation celle
de l'uniforme à l'école à partir de la
rentrée prochaine et pendant 2 ans les
établissements volontaires des bouches
duurô et d'verneuronal pourront imposer
une tenue vestimentaire commune à leurs
élèves madame la sénatrice la droite en
rêveil gabrielal l'a fait c'est un peu
ça si on devait résumer le bilan de
Gabriel
àalcz là encore il a fait preuve de
lucidité il a reconnu que il y avait une
crise sur une crise de l'école qui
touchait aux performances de notre
système éducatif et donc dès son arrivée
dès sa prise de fonction il a pris des
décisions très fortes là vous l'avez
montré sur l'uniforme l'uniforme c'est
un serpent de mer dont tous les partis
politiques se sont emparés et que
personne n'a finalement véritablement
tranché et lui tranché il a tranché il a
dit on fait une expérimentation et puis
on évalue et puis si ça marche on
généralise je trouve que c'était la
bonne méthode après ça va pas
révolutionner le système éducatif et
c'est pas ça qui va faire qu'on va
redresser le niveau de la France dans
les classements PISA en revanche là
aussi c'est difficile de juger son bilan
puisqu'il est arrivé au mois de juillet
on n' pas encore véritablement de la
comment dire de de de de de résultat là
aussi il a pris la décision sur les
groupes de niveau oui le collège
aujourd'hui unique est uniforme et qu'il
y a des écarts de niveaux dans chacun
dans chacune des classes là aussi il a
dit écoutez on va faire des groupes pour
permettre en fait à ceux qui ont des
difficultés de progresser mais à ceux
qui sont meilleurs de progresser
également c'est ce que j'appelle tout
simplement pousser l'excellence h c'est
ce que vous appelez un bon ministre de
l'Éducation encore une fois je le redis
c'est très difficile de juger il était
là depuis 4 mois mais il a pris des
décisions qui qui restaurent l'autorité
il l' également sur le harcèlement
scolaire par exemple le harcèlement
scolaire très vite il a expliqué que
c'était au harceleur de quitter
l'établissement de ce point de vue-l
aussi il a trouvé des mots justes il a
trouvé des mots forts il a été courageux
et c'est des mots qui étaient attendus
par les parents d'élèves si on reprend
également la BAA pareil il y avait une
forme de zone grise par rapport à la loi
de 2004 et bien là aussi il a permis au
chefs d'établissement comment dire de se
raccrocher à une règle et c'est cette
règle qui leur a permis de régler
beaucoup de de situation un peu délicat
dans les établissements scolair est-ce
qu' qui vous laisse un goû d'inachevé
oui complètement moi je trouve ça ge
qu'on est il y a eu trois ministres de
l'Éducation nationale pour de rentrées
scolaires alors il a été dit à un moment
que probablement il resterait également
ministre de l'éducation nationale vous
souhaitez que et écoutez si c'est
possible oui parce que ou alors il
faudrait une personnalité qui
connaissent aussi bien que lui le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale et
qui surtout est comme lui cette ce
volontarisme et ce pragmatisme parce que
ce dont souffre le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale c'est d'un
dogmatisme on avait papendia jusqu'à
maintenant on l'a vu même sur le
harcèlement scolaire qui manquait
complètement d'empathie et lui on
sentait que pour le coup il était
véritablement sur le terrain et que il
avait compris que tout passe aujourd'hui
par l'Éducation nationale et que
l'effondrement silencieux du niveau
scolaire des élèves ça n'est plus
possible ne serait-ce que pour l'avenir
de notre nation en fait et c'est vrai
qu'il avait il avait pris à bras le corp
tous ces sujets on verra et on l' vu au
moment de sa nomination ce qui était un
peu insolide d'ailleurs il était en
visionférence avec des des chefs
d'établissement il a dit lors de son
discours emmenit avec lui la cause de
l'école est-ce que du coup c'est un
mauvais signal quand même qui est envoyé
au syndicat de prof et aux enseignants
le fait d'enlever Gabriel Atal de ce
poste c'était le risque c'était le
risque parce que il est il est il est il
était très attendu encore une fois
comment dire il incarnait une forme
d'espoir pour l'éducation pourquoi parce
que il a pris des décisions il a tranché
dès sa prise de fonction sur des sujets
qui étaient extrêmement épineux délicats
sensible vis-à-vis des syndic
alors il a eu il a eu les mots en fait
sur le perron de Matignon pour dire je
pars avec la cause de l'école ça devrait
normalement apaiser les syndicats mais
j'ose espérer qu'il sera extrêmement
vigilant parce qu'encore une fois c'est
gravissime de se rendre compte
qu'aujourd'hui on a des élèves qui
arrivent en 6e et qui ne savent toujours
pas lire écrire et compter et que donc
il faut revenir aux fondamentaux de
l'école avec des choses toutes simples
de Ré prendre à lire écrire et compter à
no à nos jeunes les syndicats
d'enseignants qui déplorent ce passage
éclair rue de Grenel et il regrette que
l'éducation soit une variable
d'ajustement vous comprenez cette
critique écoutez du maronisme en général
et bien oui moi je la comprends
parfaitement parce qu'encore une fois il
est arrivé Tony Truant en disait vous
allez voir ce que vous allez voir la
crise de l'école je vais la prendre à
bras le cor et je vais régler les
problèmes et puis 4 mois après on se
rend compte finalement que sans doute ça
a été un marche-pied pour des ambitions
personnel il se trouve que le Président
de la République a fait un choix son
choix c'est de mettre un très jeune
ministre comme premier ministre c'est un
coup de comme ou un coup politique mais
en tout cas derrière ce coup politique
ce qui compte aujourd'hui c'est de
montrer qu'il a une forme de solidité à
Matignon et que il continuera de de de
comment dire de protéger notre système
scolaire et surtout de le
réformer merci Steve à tout à l'heure à
tout à l'heure on parlera d' encore de
Gabriel Atal quel suspense ce sera à
suivre dans le club merci à tout à
l'heure on va parler des des européennes
ni Sven hein ce sera le le 9 juin
prochain est-ce que la nomination de
Gabriel hatal c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle pour les républicains c'est lui
qui va porter la campagne de la majorité
pour les européennes écoutez nous on se
positionne pas par rapport au
rassemblement national euh nous ce qui
compte aujourd'hui c'est qu'on puisse
très très vite désigner notre tête de
liste qui sera j'ose l'espérer François
Xavier Bellami est-ce que vous tardez
pas trop à la désigner est-ce que ça
handicape pas le candidat
l'objec désé mais l'objectif d'éc cioti
c'était d'annoncer si possible en fait
les cinq ou six premiers de la liste
mais aujourd'hui c'est un secret de
polyinel évidemment François Xavier
béami a tous les atouts pour porter
cette liste et je trouve qu'il sera
parfait face à Jordane Bardella et à
Gabriel Atal qui sera visiblement celui
qui va porter la campagne des
européennes pour pour Renaissance et
donc nous avons nous un très très bon
bilan et il sera parfaitement bien le
défendre mais c'est sûr que je pense que
Gabriel Atal été mis là aussi parce que
c'est une forme de missile anti
bardellaa il y a quand même 10 points
d'écart entre le rassemblement national
euh et aujourd'hui euh rés de liste le
fossé le fossé est actuellement
effectivement dans les sondages en tout
cas grand entre la liste de la majorité
présidentielle et celle de Jordane
Bardella est-ce que vous pensez que
Gabriel Attal est la bonne arme de la
majorité présidentielle pour combleroutz
sans doute parce que c'est vrai que dans
les débats face à Jordan ba il fera
parfaitement le poid euh maintenant on
connaît très très bien la stratégie
d'Emmanuel Macron vous savez elle est
limpide c'est de dire c'est moi ou le
chaos et que du coup on va se retrouver
comme pendant la campagne de 2017 en
fait pour les républicains il va essayer
tout simplement de nous cornerériser
c'est-à-dire qu'il va dire qu'en gros
bah si vous êtes progressiste vous votez
Macron si vous êtes proeuropéen vous
votez Macron mais si vous êtes
nationaliste et anti-européen alors vous
votez ou bardellaa ou ou ou Jordan
Bardella et donc qui est aussi la
stratégie de Marine Le Pen d'en faire
une élection de miandat une élection
d'opposition pour montrer qu'elle elle
incarne l'opposition à Emmanuel Macron
quelle place du coup pour vous et bien
voilà c'est tout le sujet c'est-à-dire
que il faut qu'on sorte de ce
bipartisisme parce que le vrai sujet
c'est que demain il y aura forcément une
alternance parce que le macronisme ne
survivra pas Emmanuel Macron et
qu'Emmanuel Macron ne sera pas candidat
la prochaine fois et gabrielal ne peut
pas être l'héritier ça c'est de la
politique fiction on n'en sait rien mais
le vrai sujet c'est de savoir puisqu'il
y aura cette alternance est-ce que c'est
les républicains qui incarnent cette
alternance ou alors ce sont l'épaule de
radicalité euh actuellement donc nous on
se bat justement pour que persiste en
France une droite républicaine et ça me
semble fondamental encore une fois parce
que malgré l'accident industriel que
nous avons subi à la présidentielle avec
les 4,7 % et bien notre électorat ne
s'est pas évaporé et on l'a bien vu sur
la loi immigration la France est
aujourd'hui de droite toutes nos mesures
ont été plébiscitées celles qui ont été
portées notamment par Bruno rotillot au
Sénat et donc la France attend de la
clarté sur les sujets de sécurité sur
les sujets d'immigration sur le pouvoir
d'achat sur la transition écologique qui
ne doit pas rimer avec effondrement
économique sur tous ces sujets là nous
n'avons pas de honte à avoir la droite
doit porter ses convictions continuer de
défendre ses valeurs parce qu'encore une
fois sinon ce seront les pôles de
radicalité mais est-ce qu'elles sont
encore audit vous avez rappelé le score
de Valérie PCR François Xavier béami
lors des dernières européennes il a fait
un petit peu plus de 8 % est-ce que
cette élection c'est un peu kitouou pour
les LR est-ce que ça pourrait être la
dernière j'espère que non parce
qu'encore une fois la
droite porte un message sur l'Europe qui
est une Europe des nations nous ne
sommes pas pour une Europe fédérale et
il faut que l'Europe redevienne
puissante qu'elle puisse se réconcilier
avec la défense de nos intérêts la
défense de nos entreprises la défense de
nos agriculteurs et donc je suis
convaincu que c'est notre projet qui
créera la surprise avec encore une fois
une tête de liste qui a toute la
crédibilité pour porter le projet des
républicains on va terminer en parlant
de l'actualité dans votre région de
l'actualité de Paris notamment on
retrouve pour ça Jacques Paquier bonjour
Jacques merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
rédacteur en chef du journal du Grand
Paris on est ravi de vous retrouver JAC
avec vous on revient sur les finances de
la Ville de Paris oui absolument vous
parliez Agnès Sven de d'alternance et de
de gouvernance si vous arriviez aux
affaires après-demain à la mairie de
Paris sur quoi vous feriez les économies
vous vous vous fustigez souvent la la
dette qui progresser une mauvaise
gestion Pier Bournazel par exemple
propose le non remplacement d'un départ
à la retraite sur trois est-ce que c'est
une mesure que vous mettriez en en place
ou sinon où est-ce que vous souhaiteriez
réduire la la la voilure si demain vous
vous êtes élu à la mairie de de Paris
oui alors c'est une très très bonne
question parce que il faut quand même
dire que la dette a explosé de 600 % en
20 ans et que annieidalgo a trahi toutes
ses promesses de ne pas augmenter les
impôts et donc d'abord nous avec Rachid
adati qui est notre présidente de groupe
au Conseil de Paris nous avons euh nous
avons demandé évidemment un audit
indépendant pour l'évaluation des
politiques publiques vous vous rendez
compte qu'aujourd'hui malgré ces 10
milliards de dettes 10 milliards de
dettes on se demande d'ailleurs où est
passé cet argent c'est absolument euh
inacceptable puisque quand on regarde
les services publics on a une ville qui
est encore plus dangereuse une ville qui
est encore plus sale et une ville encore
plus bétonnée donc comme je le disais
premièrement ce que nous demandons c'est
un audit indépendant des politiques
publiques puisquen fait il n'y a jamais
aucune étude d'impact sur l'argent qui
est utilisé ensuite évidemment il faut
une une réduction des dépenses on l'a vu
là le budget 2024 qui a été examiné au
Conseil de Paris il y a l'effet ciseau
c'est-à-dire que les dépenses augmentent
beaucoup plus que les recettes et donc
on demande une réduction des dépenses
pour éviter de continuer à augmenter les
impôts je le rappelle que la taxe
financière a augmenté de 62 %. donc je
pense que Pierry Bournazel a sans doute
a sans doute raison mais il faut revoir
aussi la politique des ressources
humaines quand on voit que il y a 50000
fonctionnaires qui sont employés on se
demande à quoi ils servent est-ce qu'il
faudrait pas de ce de ce point de vue-
là aussi
rationaliser tout ce qui concerne les
dépenses de fonctionnement plus que les
dépenses d' d'investissement donc sur
tous ces sujetsl euh encore une fois la
la Cour des comptes d'ailleurs a étrié
le la gestion absolument calamiteuse
Danny dalgo en matière de de finances
publique vous rendez compte 10 milliards
de dettes à la limite si on avait 10
milliards de dettes et que Paris était
une ville sûre une ville propre une
ville où il fait bon de vivre où on
arrivait à se loger non on voit
aujourd'hui que chaque année on a de
plus en plus de familles qui quittent
Paris parce que c'est devenu une ville
extrêmement chère et
que c'est une ville maintenant pour les
plus aisés ou les plus aidés et donc
cette situation est devenue intenable
justement merci beaucoup madame la
sénatrice et et ça ça tombe bien je
voulais vous demander votre avis sur le
logement puisque on on en parle et
certains demande d'ailleurs que Gabriel
Atal prenne se saisisse en fin ce ce
sujet le logement à Paris on le sait
c'est des des prix de des loyers
exorbitant quel regard portez-vous sur
le PLU bioclimatique de Paris dont
l'enquête publique vient de s'ouvrir qui
vise notamment à imposer du logement
social dans certains dans certains
bâtiments et à restreindre la
constructibilité au n de la transition
écologique vous parliez d'un Paris
bétonné quel serait madame even vos
solutions face à cette équation qu' sait
complexe écoutez là aussi juste pardon
le le PLU c'est le plan local
d'urbanisme oui voilà tout monde
comprenne bien
exactement là aussi le PLU n'est
absolument pas à la hauteur des enjeux
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure Paris a été
bétonné 3 millions de mètres carrés
construits c'est ça le bilan de Madame
Hidalgo et donc ce PLU qui était censé
réparer toutes les erreurs de Madame
Hidalgo n'est absolument pas à la
hauteur et donc d'ailleurs il ne
respecte même pas les accords de Paris
les accords de Paris ne seront pas
respectés
donc là aussi je trouve que Madame
hiidalgo fait beaucoup d'annonces mais
qui ne sont jamais suivies des faits sur
le PLU bioclimatique elle passe son
temps à s'onorer d'être la ville la plus
verte d'Europe et c'est tout l'inverse
il y a des projets one qui coûtent des
projets pardon
urbains qui sont des aberrations
écologiques le projet one Bercy
Charenton la Tour Triangle moi-même je
suis élu du 15e arrondissement et donc
là aussi c'est totalement orthogonal
avec tout ce qu'elle a dit jusqu'à
maintenant donc puisque vous m'intérogz
sur le B plu bioclimatique voilà je vous
le redis il est absolument pas à la
hauteur des enjeux merci Jacques Paquier
merci beau beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous la Une du journal du Grand Paris on
la regarde face au cyberattaque la
réponse des collectivités franciliennes
c'est à la Une de votre journal merci
Jacques merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité pendant cette première demi-heure
on é ravi de vous recevoir